okay last week I said I need the
audience to tell me should we continue
classic interviews on our friday show
which is an old interview that i record
a new introduction to or analysis of or
as we've done the last two weeks should
we replace the classic interview with a
second segment of phone calls in our
second friday segment we do live calls
and normally in the third segment we do
a classic interview the last two weeks
and this week as well we're going to try
taking calls for both segments i put out
a call to people saying let me know
which we should do hundreds of responses
every response feeling very strongly but
no consensus no consensus at all
stephanie said i love the interview than
I hate live cults Jen said I prefer
extra phone calls rather than classic
interviews it's better to remain current
and the phone calls are more current
Alex said ditch the classic interviews
more live calls i like your interviews
but not the classic ones i don't totally
get that because every classic interview
was once a regular interview but i don't
know i think he just means he likes the
interviews when they're about current
event out going on today fair enough sky
i absolutely love the interviews
couldn't care less about the live calls
on and on and on and then Jeremy said
I've enjoyed about eighty-five percent
of the interviews and seventy percent of
the live calls so you would assume that
i prefer the interviews but the
anticipation of what some [ __ ] might
say over the phone makes it about equal
sorry this probably didn't help yes
hundreds of messages most of them useful
that one from jeremy saying that he's
basically neutral not the most useful
email we received right i mean it sounds
like the audience has deliberated and
there's a hung jury on this one yo
what's going to be the results you think
i think what we will do is alternate one
week we will do one segment of live
calls and then a classic interview the
next week we will double up on live
calls this is the only way i can really
think of providing everybody with
something that would to some degree of
please then right yeah we can please
everyone on this i'm sure there will be
no dissent on this one yeah or we please
nobody which is usually more common what
were that that's usually the more
common response so that's the direction
I am leaning right now we will alternate
this week we will do double live calls
but then next week we will do a classic
interview and then the week after that
we will switch back and we'll see what
people think I don't know I mean
genuinely I don't know the best way to
handle it because class the interviews
are all available on YouTube but
sometimes relating an older interview to
what's going on now people like and also
people won't necessarily go with years
into the archives for those older
interviews so it's a great way to expose
the new viewers and listeners to older
content yes but the live calls tend to
be more current and sometimes it's hard
to relate the classic interviews to
what's going on today so maybe we should
force that as much yeah but if there's a
clear connection between what happened a
couple years ago whenever I ask speaking
about and some recent news story I think
we should definitely go with the classic
interviews in that instance I like it
yeah I like that idea so anyway that's
the tentative plan I 08 hundreds of
emails from people telling me why this
is a wrong approach